Mercy Pereira is struggling to keep the
home fires burning her electricity has
been disconnected because she couldn't
pay her bill which is increased in
recent months
when Al Jazeera met her last year she
was supplying food to a local eatery now
I had to give up selling string Hoppers
gas kerosene flour and a lot of prices
increased so I couldn't manage now I
provide meals to some students who are
lodging nearby I'm managing with great
difficulty
foreign
among hundreds of thousands of Sri
Lankans not just the poorest
president
his government say they have turned the
economy around
the recovery plan has seen inflation
which peaked at 65 percent last year
falling to single digits for the first
time since 2021.
but poverty has increased to 25 percent
and a large number of people have lost
their jobs
the situation has been a challenge for
those running the government's social
welfare program which has tried to
cushion those worst affected
when we compare with the last five years
you know that we had a
safety net program for the poor and
poorest people only about 1.702 million
right but this time we call the
application we received 3.7 million
analysts say things have been stabilized
but warned there is much more that needs
to be done before Sri Lanka is on the
road to recovery we have stopped things
getting worse at the speed there were
but have we turned around I think minute
we haven't yet turned around because
turning the corner would mean that we
have stopped reducing our GDP but up to
the second quarter of this year GDP kept
Contracting
that means we also were losing jobs in
the economy month on month despite the
sharp drop in inflation and interest
rates prices remain high
one year on the government says things
are on the mend there are no more cues
inflation has fallen and worker
remittances have increased but many
people here are still struggling to earn
a living Fernandez Al Jazeera Colombo